this is my first trip to the land of a
thousand lakes otherwise known as the
Mecklenburg Lake District which is in
north eastern Germany there's water as
far as the eye can see it's so peaceful
this is like a postcard of the region
the view of Germany's largest lake the
mullets from this church tower in verbal
and I'm going to explore macklenburg
lake district with a houseboat
I don't need a license to pilot the boat
around the lakes but I do need some
basic instructions hello hi I'm Ralph
Lucas let's go aboard better soon
lawyers kids right and you primos done
below are your quarters on the port side
is the first cabin oh and over here is a
toilet and the shower now we'll go up to
the salon which is also the control room
this is the echosounder very important
because it will help us avoid running a
ground but the best view is from up on
the dailies have a hero and a name pass
done look at all the signs I have to
learn you have me here tomorrow or that
signal horn won't you have it but it's
not to be blown in the harbor that is
bad nautical manners heyyy right left
wedding in any storable starboard port
site let's set sail that's andreas my
colleague he's coming along for the ride
finally we can begin our adventure
I'm doing pretty well Lake mullets is
very big and spacious and there is not
much traffic so it's a great place for a
beginner to practice his skippering
skills
we're now in vagan the biggest town on
lake mullets and right in the middle of
a popular holiday spot
it's also where you find the museum
nature discovery center there I can
learn more about the nature here in the
lake district and in move its national
park oh for sure in the garden I meet
biologists majeika vawa of course
there's more to be found here than ducks
and swans indoors there are aquariums
with all kinds of local fish so that's
sturgeon is good and that one over there
what's that one of us that's a green and
behind it is a pike perch right now i'm
adam sandler the homeless then you tell
us why visitors to the region should
come here to the museum that's me let's
say I'm 70th exam is all about the
natural environment in the region
especially the flora and fauna of the
mecklenburg lake district so there are
lots of fish of course here you can
learn about the ecology of the local
lakes and rivers there are many other
plants and animals and if you come here
first then you'll know what you're
looking at or what to look out for when
you're out exploring it's a different
experience if we've been here first one
done coke sister 70 my guns on us listen
again san jose lopez was the highlight
the biggest attraction here at the
Museum as those on vista schools are
probably a really big draw at the moment
is our golden pike it's very unusual
because it's a kind of albino that's why
it has this golden yellow color it's
very rare listen is eight night
personally I found the huge school of
whitefish pretty impressive
hi time to get into the water myself a
little chilly at 20 degrees Celsius but
clean the water and the lake district
gets top marks for water quality here we
called pike pass tench sometimes we've
also got perch trout and charm this is
making me hungry and while it's great to
be able to cook on board I'd rather get
some freshly smoked fish that's been
caught right here in the lake here is
our lovely smokehouse it's very
traditional nice and black it has seen
plenty of fish in its time in the olden
days you couldn't put fish in the deep
freeze so they preserved fish by smoking
them Matthew Douglas if you like the
traditional rustic way of life and the
aroma a smokehouse is the place to be
I'm snow Barbara tech company that
smoked eel looks good thank you it's a
fine specimen and we found the perfect
spot to drop anchor on the moods
this is the life
I'm up early and it's a lovely morning
on the lake the wind is up and the air
is fresh
the water is pretty chubby huh haha
great
and as our cruise draws to a close I'm
going to show off some of the skills I
have learned here on Lake move its
people on shore or on the other boats
really enjoy watching amateur skippers
struggle to maneuver their boats into
the birth punish its high turnover
I made it total freedom on the
mecklenburg lakes so much water so much
nature and I've only seen a small part
of it so I definitely have to come back
again
you